قبيل الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا كانت
الولايات المتحده اكثر الاصوات في ضروره
الاستعداد لها ثم لما اندلعت الحرب كانت
الاكثر انخراطا فيها تسليحا وتمويلا من
بين جميع الدول الغربيه الان يبدو ان لغه
جديده تصدر عن واشنطن اسمعتها لاوكرانيا
سرا وتكفلت صحيفه الوطن
فكان الطلب لاوكرانيا
فلا بد من المفاوضات مع روسيا لاظهار
انفتاحكم على هذا المسار ولو من اجل طمئنه
عالمي ضربه حياته في اكثر من بلد بسبب
الحرب
مستشار الامن القومي
التقى الرئيس الاوكرانيه بلدميرجنسكي يؤكد
له اصطناع الدعم الامريكي الذي كان اخره
مبلغ 400 مليون دولار وهو ما رفع جمله
المساعدات الامريكيه لاوكرانيا الى اكثر
من 18 مليار دولار منذ الحرب ومع الدعم
سيكون الطالب
في الموقف الامريكي اذا لم يكن امرا
تكتكيا عابرا يهدف الى مزيد من تعريه
روسيا كقوه غاشمه تمارس ارهابا وغزوا
واحتلالا لاراضي اوكرانيا فانه لا يعدم
ايضا ما يجعله تحولا مرتبطا بصميم المصالح
الامريكيه وفي مقدمتها استدامه الهيمنه
بوصف امريكا القوه العظمى في العالم
عسكريا واقتصاديا
نظر تحول المزاج ظهرت قبل اسبوعين عندما
طالب 30 عضوا في الكونغرس الرئيس الامريكي
بتغيير مقاربته للحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا بالبحث والعمل على تحقيق تسويه
سلميه وجدل النواب انهم مؤتمنون على اموال
دافع الضرائب الامريكي ولا يرون الذهاب في
مواصله استنزاف هذه الاموال بالخطه
الرشيده وهناك خشيه من ان الرئيس اذا لم
يفعل ذلك مختارا فقط يجد نفسه مقره عليه
اذا قدر للجمهوريين ان يغير معادله القوه
في الكونجرس بعد الانتخابات النصفيه لكن
ما هو اخطر من كل ذلك هو ان الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا كشفت عمهادات متحديات حقيقيه
تواجه الولايات المتحده فمن جهه هناك
دائما التهديد النووي الذي شكل في مرحله
جزء من خطاب الحرب خاصه بعد اعلان موسكو
انها لن توفر شيئا مما في يدها من اذا تم
تحديد مصالحها وسلامه اراضيها وهذا تحديد
يحمل الولايات المتحده مسؤوليه اكثر اتجاه
حلفائها الاوروبيين الموجودين في عين
العاصفه النوويه اذا قامت وبذر هذا
الاحتمال يشكل دافعا قويا للاوروبيين
لمراجعه اعتمادهم الكامل على الولايات
المتحده بل ربما حملهم على الاتجاه شرقا
كما فعل المستشار الالماني بزيارته
الاخيره للصين انها المراجعه التي
اقتضضتها ايضا ازمه الطاقه حيث وقع
الانكشاف الاوروبي الاستراتيجي في مساله
تتصل بمطلوبات عيش المواطن الاوروبي
ولكثيلين بدله السياسه الامريكيه متصله
بالحرب كما لو انها قوه تنشط في تجنيد
الخصوم وتجميعهم
فجزء من زياده مفاعيل التقارب الروسي
الصيني المتطوره باتجاه اي يكون نواه لحلف
يضم المغبونين من السياسه الامريكيه اصبح
امرا مشهودا والولايات المتحده وجدت نفسها
مواجهه بمهددات الاستراتيجيات ظاهره ماثله
تمثلها روسيا واخرى كامله كالصين لكن
نموها الاقتصاديه والعسكريه المطارد ليس
مما يغيب عن رؤيه السياسيين والعسكريين
الى الامريكيين وهناك دوله كبيره ما
استقامت لها علاقه طبيعيه مع امريكا منذ
اكثر من 43 عاما ايران ستجد نفسها في هذا
المعسكر كوريا الشماليه التي تقف على
برنامج النووي بعيد عن المراقبه وتتلاها
باطلاق الصواريخ القادره على حمل الرؤوس
النوويه كميه تلحى باطلاق الطائرات
الورقيه هي ايضا مهدد ظاهر وكامل هؤلاء
جميعا ومعهم دول لا تجاهروا بذلك يطلبون
نظام عالميا جديدا تنتهي فيه الهيمنه
الامريكيه وتقوم الاخطاب المتعدده لا
تسلكوا العالم في نمط ثقافي وسياسي
واقتصاديا واحد ما تخرجت عنه كنت مارقه
ودعوه الاوكرانيين الى التفاوض ربما كانت
نزولا على اكراهات لا تسلم منها حتى القوه
العظمى